bill burr just dropped a new special
and he's really revolutionizing the
comedy game i've been in the game 12
years yoshi's been in the game i think
seven years now
and basically
when i started comedy and like before
that the traditional route of becoming a
comedian was literally just like
fighting for stage time grinding it out
on the road trying to suck up to
gatekeepers that probably never even did
stand up
and now
a lot of the comedians that came up in
that system
are being very proactive and helping
younger comics not have to struggle in
that way and bill burr
i will say is probably at the forefront
of this in terms of everything he's
doing with all things comedy and
creating and just a network for
comedians to create content and be
themselves and have their own voice and
he just released this netflix special
he's produced comedy specials
this is a guy doing it at a very high
level and what really struck with me
with this comedy special is there was
there's a comedian named steph tolev who
he actually saw on instagram and then
put her on the show so
he's really setting a new standard for
just comedy and the route to quote
making it is no longer like the
gatekeeper and then sucking up and
praying for a chance but it's really
like get funny and
get opportunities
for sure and i think that's just an
awesome thing to see
like people at the top of the echelon
doing that because that changes the
entire game for everybody right like you
know like you said it's like
you are
that open micro and you hope somebody
sees you and then hopefully you go to
hosting hopefully you produce some stuff
and then you hopefully try to feature
for somebody and then hopefully you get
to headline like it's that sort of step
by step by step but to your point it's
all been
serviced by the gatekeepers they're like
ah it's time for you to go to hosting or
it's time for you to go to feature and
now it's time for you to go to like
headline work and all these comedians
like especially bill burr
like there's other people that are doing
this that i think is like phenomenal as
well of just bringing other people up
you've got like
chapelle
i mean chappelle did the special for
uh earthquake which is
how we got the earthquake scale right
[Laughter]
marlon williams is doing some stuff off
for hbo max you got tiffany haddish
doing she's ready yeah two volumes of
that you know what i mean nate bargati
has uh a special coming up that he's
doing for uh mike vecchio um you even
got people like you know i think about
just people bringing other people up
people like nick cannon bringing up all
those comedians all those like sort of
he brought up like a bunch of vine
comedians
and just comedians who were just like
doing different stuff and put them on
his show of wild and out yeah sure like
it's changing the game
where comedians are rewriting the rules
of what's supposed to happen for you to
get to that level and i think that's
freaking awesome
yeah and it's not it's not a new concept
i mean back in the 80s rodney
dangerfield did this series like the
young comedians special is what it was
called and it was like a showcase that
really launched the careers of people
like sam kinnison and like bob saget i
mean seinfeld was on there i mean a lot
of the big names louis anderson roseanne
barr i mean a lot of those big names
rodney was known to be a champion for
inner comics and he put on this
show that i think it ended up going like
15 seasons or something just showcasing
young comics so i think
there's an example of it but to now see
it at this level and as you listed so
many different people doing it now and
at a real like
tiffany haddish's
uh they ready specials the people on
that show got executive producer credits
you know
um
what uh bill burr produced a comedy
special for his buddy paul verzi that
appeared
on comedy central but they actually
retained ownership of it so paul all
things comedy despite it being on comedy
central they still owned the
intellectual property of this comedy
special so all the leverages with
comedians now and more than ever and um
bill burr is doing at the highest level
but you can even think at any level
where can you find leverage i mean hot
breath
every month we do this hundred dollar
joke contest where the winner
gets an enter 100 bucks and an interview
on hot breath you know to be on the same
show as comics like paul versi as like
jeff foxworthy and andrew schultz so
it's whatever level you're at how can
you
use what you have to help elevate other
comedians is really kind of the top
hopefully trickle-down
um
uh effect of someone like bill bird
doing a type of special like this
yeah i mean i think it's just it's just
cool to rewrite the rules right
and
you know i think we've we've preached
this that the way that you're gonna
really get on in comedy is through
friends
and networking like that's really what
it is but it's about being positive like
at the end of the day nobody wants to
work with an a-hole you know i'm saying
like nobody wants to and so being good
at an open mic being like
respectful at an open mic being
respectful even at a club that you want
to
like work at will get you so much
further
and at the end of the day that's what
those other comedians pick up on you
know i think you told me about stephen
rogers he was just doing comedy and
somebody saw him and was like oh we
should put you on
uh
colbert you mean it's like
you're just doing the work versus like
trying to wait for these other
gatekeepers to like
get you there
yeah and the big thing as i referenced
early on in comedy there was like a
scarcity mentality of like oh there's
not enough for everyone there's not
enough to go around
but there is and actually the more you
can spread it around the more comes back
around as well oh that's bars
that's bar i need i need to get a bar
sound effect
that's bars right there
the more you spread around the more
comes around it's and it's true and it's
true and i'm hoping that newer comics
can really
adopt this mentality of there's enough
to go around and i think
the big
like we we see like bill burr and
whatnot and like what he's doing at his
level and sometimes i knew her comic
baby like well how does that affect me
beyond oh maybe bill burr
will see me on instagram posting my
grainy crowd work clip
you know um that i'm trying to go viral
with at that coffee shop in front of
four people
but i think
go ahead were you gonna say something
no no i think you're you're bringing up
on on a point of like or you can make it
a dope clip and you just do a lot of it
right yeah get a camera get a good like
you know
angle put captions do all the things
that you know works for you know the
social media stuff now at the end of the
day people have
tried so many different things but when
you see the people popping off even like
akash singh
and ancient jolts the way that they
popped off they just made a whole bunch
of those clips they just put everything
out in the ether and people start it
started gaining traction started gaining
traction and that's what they use for
leverage and that's how andrew schultz
got the netflix special that's andrew
schultz got his own show and it's being
sponsored by a bunch of people and
they're just raking in the money and
everyone on his team is an executive
producer of the show
you mean it's like yeah that's like
that's how
that comedy sort of engine runs now and
i think that's that's just it's not only
cool but it's like it's
kind of inspiring man i think that's the
coolest part about doing comedy now it's
like yeah okay
it's not a one-trick pony any longer
yeah so and i don't want people i don't
want to say don't post clips but it's
like if steph
posted some grainy not great clip hoping
she would go viral on it and that's the
one bill burr saw
you know if you post something on the
internet you know it's
it's out there forever you know so keep
that in mind when you're just spraying
all this content of like you never know
who's gonna see it and when that may be
the person that wants to book you at a
certain time or it's bill burr wanting
you to like go on his comedy special
with him
fax
so the big i think the big thing
i'm hoping young commas can take away
from this discussion is
to
focus on what you can control you know
not trying to suck up to certain
gatekeeper
or try to get on somewhere because
that's where the cool kids are whatever
but like what can you control
you're not in with your comedy scene
okay you can't control how much you're
writing you can't control maybe going
and producing your own show you can't
control trying to get out into other
comedy scenes you can't control how nice
and easy you are to work with focusing
on what you can control will start to
bring those opportunities to you and
this took me eight years to discover but
focusing on what you can control is
really the key to unlocking
whatever your comedy success definition
is
for sure and tony mentioned
that he's an introvert and i think
i'm starting to understand that most
comedians are actually introverts
um
in the sense of they just like
the thoughts that are in their head
which is why they go on the stage and
spit them out but being introverted
doesn't stop you from networking
it doesn't stop you from being nice
like and i think it's not really about
like being like a social butterfly like
me and joel are very different social
butterfly that's this guy social
butterfly that's not this guy right
yeah that's not me
yeah but we still network when we're at
shows you know i mean we're still nice
to everyone at the show we still perform
at the highest level
all those things are part of networking
you know what i mean it's like
it doesn't mean that you're like have to
be friends with everybody it just means
you just got to be nice in the room
you mean like and yeah
take account that
somebody's probably watching that you
don't even think is watching so just be
on your game all the time that's really
what it kind of comes down to is like
even if you're working bits
work those bits at the top of your game
figure you know that's what the open mic
is for it's for you to figure them out
but don't you know just don't do it half
ass is the best way to describe it like
focus on what you can do well and then
do that a lot
and just keep getting better it's kind
of like the one percent rule how do you
get better one percent every single day
that stuff adds up to by the time you
know you're a headliner you're like all
right i figured a lot of this stuff out
and then i'm still gonna figure more out
later
kaboom
bars bars bars
so that is how
bill burr is changing the comedy game
right there my friends
putting the control into your hands my
friends so focus on what you can control
is the name of the